I have played the first mission of the
new game by slithering Stargate
timekeepers and I'm going to tell you
what I think is it a thumbs up or a
thumbs down welcome to Sid trk your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie
[Music]
Channel I'm going to kick this video off
by being very honest I'm not a gamer I'm
45 years old I think the last game I
played was if you take Football manager
out of the equation because I do play
that quite a lot played civilization
that's that's good I like that and like
red alert when I was younger I used to
play those games like military you know
like build up forces and go and batter
people I actually entered a competition
once and came in the top 1% of um
Command and Conquer edert so I did quite
well I came like 50th or something out
of like 5,000 some people but anyway so
I'm not really the best person is what
I'm saying but Harris and Matthew are
younger than me and do play games and
they've both played it too and at the
end of this video um this very quick
review there's going to be some of the
gameplay and um quite a long review by
Harris where he destroys it I have to
admit he viscer the game he is not a fan
Matthew seem to like it a little bit
more but let me tell you about the game
and what to
expect this is not action-packed this is
quite a slow game it's a cerebral game
it requires you to solve puzzles it
requires you to very slowly move through
the map you have to make sure that you
avoid any major conflict you have to
behave like almost like a special forces
operative there isn't a lot of action
there isn't a lot of
fast-paced any to be honest it's a very
immersive game though and if you like
starget you're going to like the opening
sequence you're going to like going
through the gate you're going to like
all these things the story line is split
up into seven chapters they do go
through different periods of time
through the Stargate franchise so when
the full game comes out on December 12th
we are going to have you know look
forward to that I have heard rumors and
I don't know how accurate they are but I
have heard several rumors now
but actually the game was Rewritten and
redesigned after the Amazon sale to fit
in with what Amazon had in mind for the
future Stargate franchise so actually by
playing the game you might get an idea
of what Amazon and MGM are planning to
do you might
not I am going to say this game though
and I would I I so wanted to like it I
really really wanted to like it this is
a Stargate game for God's sake it's the
first new Stargate thing we've had in a
while even you know comics and books and
things we haven't had anything for a bit
I do love that this shows a support for
Stargate you know that they're actually
releasing a game but I am going to
compare it to the recent expanse game
that I did also have a go at and I've
got to say the graphics for this game
are not great from Slytherin they're
okay it looks like a a mobile game it
looks like something play my phone but
it isn't it's on my
PC that's a bit poor it actually does
look like a game I'd have played 20
years ago when I was a kid you know it's
like Command and Conquer sort of thing
it's they're better than that but not
loads I was not blown away but this is
just the initial demo I don't know if
the actual full game will be a little
bit different it might have a slightly
higher resolution Etc so um I'm I'm not
going to I'm not going to panic too much
about
that but it just feels a little bit
unfinished it's
slow it's really slow and again if you
compare it to the recent expanse
game it's it's it mind numbingly slow I
mentioned that I used to play
Civilization um I haven't played it for
a couple of years but when I played
civilization I could
lose three four hours I mean I could
suddenly realize it's 2 o'clock in the
morning I've really got to stop playing
this game I'll just take that Nick City
and then I'll stop playing you don't get
that sense with this timekeepers game
you very much just get the sense
of okay that'll do um you know you I
wanted to finish it but there was no way
I was going to for one I played for
about an hour and I was bored I was not
enjoying it we'll put it that way now I
know Matthew is a little Keener I know
Harris hated it but as I say this review
is coming from me and I'm not a big
gamer and I will remind you as well that
if you like slow placed very immersive
games you're going to love this because
it's that type of game if you want to
play Gran Turismo play Gran Turismo if
you want to play something with lots of
bullets and guns and action and fast
pace go and play you know GTA or
something it's not that kind of game it
is for Stargate fans it is for fans of
you know puzzles and it is for people
that want to go nice and slowly through
a game and really use your
brain I apparently am not that type of
person I like movies that explode I
don't like movies that win best P
Picture Oscar you know and this feels
like a game that would win best picture
Oscar it's clever it's thoughtful as I
said it's immersive
but it's a bit
boring so guys there's some of the game
playay foll please go and check it out
please go and actually support the game
um and if if it's a game that you enjoy
please tell us um we have had a few
subscribers you know telling us what
they thought of the game and it's really
been a mixed bag some have loved it some
have thought it was not for them so I
feel that you know if you buy this game
you really do need to know what you're
buying and if you're expecting something
fast-paced and exciting you're going to
be disappointed but if you want
something immersive you're going to love
it I think that's a fair assessment and
that is the sidre review now check out
some of the game pay and hold on for
Harris's um assessment and review of
this it's beautiful he doesn't hold back
if you are new to the channel don't
forget to do all those like And
subscribe stuff and we'll see you next
time oh press any button to continue I
was waiting for something to happen CL
and Miles head for the SC you heard the
at down they
[Music]
not can we just have this battle in a
video game like
[Music]
please there she
[Applause]
see
down hey over here there's our buddy
Max
Max you going to give me a hand
yeah no
ma' can you
move are you uh
okay I'm alive is there anyone else here
no one that's breathing what about sg1
have you heard anything yeah over here
I'll show you it's nice to see that x302
like actually standing next to a human
being you know gives you like an actual
like size model obviously we've had that
before but it's been like justo just I
can't even say the word just
just just toose I don't know what I was
trying to say just toose against like a
green screen so it always made it like
ah you could never like really gauge the
size of an x302 this is only chapter
one of starget eke Keepers the full game
isn't released yet it's actually going
to be released on December the 12th
so we have a release
date what that means for Stargate the TV
showmovie whatever the hell is coming we
don't know but we did hear rumors that
the the game was delayed because they
were waiting on amson to announc
Stargate
Now read into that what you will they've
now got a release date for Stargate time
keyers that might mean we're actually
going to get a release date or an
announcement date very very soon for
Stargate which I'm very excited about
but that's not why we're here today
we're here today to play the
game
but oh is that somebody under there
that's a few people under
here what the hell does R&B to move
mean cuz R&B are not working and then R
is nowhere near M
andb right Mouse
button David you are a lifesaver um this
this plays like it's a game from 2005
Starship Troopers cuz it I I was
expecting it to be a little more
advanced than that um real quick
Graphics
Ultra let's see if that does if it
doesn't run
well we'll we'll switch it up oh God
it's already being weird is that okay
are we are we okay are we there resume
the game let's go oh with it
now move the mouse cursor and click R&B
to walk to its location or double click
R&B to run
there oh all
right either have Max can stun targets
with a physical attack no no
chance well I lasted long on this
one
remember when you hit someone to tie
them uh to when you hit someone to tie
them up after also you don't have to
kill everyone stealth is key oh I'm not
killing people I'm supposed to be
stealthy they didn't tell me that what
the
hell let's
go no
problem can I steal his weapon Oscar
Mike all right all right come
on let me press skip is there a skip we
don't need to go through this
again no
problem
oh [__]
unable oh God they're all on me now
F what the [__] did that fail okay we'll
do that
again if we've got a really powerful
weapon then Anubis is right where we
want him his whole Fleet is here only if
we can find and control the tech if we
lose this battle we might have a new God
come morning nothing Dam your rosy
Outlook how the hell's the camo
work I'm trying to figure out the camo
BS I like the camo idea but the damn
camo is
not my R is now
charged keep for opportunity to
highlight places where you can use
environment to your
advantage no
problem here we
go Oscar
Mike
let's
go now you're
talking damn
[Music]
it out your
weapons here we go
H the new video I've not seen the new
video yet I'll watch it in a
bit I'm about ready to give up on this
but let me give you my actual review
this is my my review for Jamie on Sid
Trek let me let me put myself up in here
all right
so Stargate timekeepers
is
a decent game
no it's not I I I I I was trying to see
the light at the end of the tunnel there
Stargate timekeepers is not what it
should be it really should be much
better this is not the foray into the
Stargate world and universe that we
would like to Herald us into a new show
at all of course it doesn't have to have
that stipulation on it but it does
nonetheless this is not what we want as
a fan base as a community leading into a
new show this isn't what we want as a
game in general this game is way too
convoluted in the first mission
typically in a game your first mission
is tutorial based and like you get along
you go along and you learn things as you
go this was that but not at the same
time it was far too much shoved down
your throat immediately instead of just
trying to like let you get used to the
world it's there's no exploration
involved this feels much more like a
phone game it shouldn't be a steam game
I don't know where the game developers
chose that foray into this but it it was
the the wrong one um it is a bit of a
slow burn
but it's so
slow that you forget the the wick on the
candle's even burning you're just
letting Dynamite go at that point and
there's nothing to explode either and of
course this is just the demo this is
just the first mission but the fact that
the entire demo is the first mission and
the first mission you are struggling to
get through the entire time I don't know
a soul that's completed it yet I've only
known a couple that have actually played
the game but I do not know a soul that's
completed it yet and they're all
Stargate Fanatics myself included
so if I have to give a four out of five
on Stargate eke Keepers I'm giving it a
two if I'm giving it out of 10 I'm
probably giving it a three and a half to
a four somewhere in that range it's not
a good game it has the potential to be
decent I'm about ready to give up on
this because I only plan on being on
this for an hour and I don't think an
hour is long enough for this
game so I'm gonna need to spend a little
bit more
time and I have to go eat dinner in a
minute so if I save it there I'm not
giving up on the game I literally have
to go because I only plan on being on
here for an
hour I said to my Ms I'm going to be
streaming for an hour or so and then
we'll eat dinner thinking that this game
is going to take not that long because
it's only chapter one but no I feel like
I'm going to be spending a lot of time
on this game which I'm happy
about because I want to when I when I
eventually play this game I want to play
the entire thing and I don't want it to
feel like a
waste but I do like it I really do this
is really good
game little bit frustrating with the
controls but once you I feel like once
I've got them a little bit
better I should be
[Music]
fine